Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome to Prison Island.
Now, this is a horror game that's currently in development. It's actually freeeeeee
eeokay, it's free so it's not even like early access but it's
supposedly when you're stuck on an island and you're trying to not die?
Yes? I think? I'm not 100% sure actually..
[game narrator speaking Portuguese]
ookay...
I'm sorry..
Oooh...
Oh. Oh! Wait no - am I? Oooo
Uh-oh.. I hear something!
wOaah O.O
[BEEEEEEEP] OoOh
[more narration begins]
Also it's a .. Brazilian - por- It's in Portuguese
Okay..
I'm 28 years old..
[Mark.exe is processing]
Huh.. Okay
aaAlright
Okay, Prison Island. I get it. All right. Whoa. It's-It'sa an island, and it's a prison. I get it. VERY scary.. Alright..
Whoa-ho! I landed with quite a thwump!
Oh hello.. there's weird boxes in the sky..
ookay..  ooooh
What is that?
What am I seeing?
Ohgh I- I've got two frames a second
Ooooh boy..
Okay.. A little strange. What in the hell is happening here?
aah
[Dramatic music kicks up]
AH- Why you rumblin so bumbly??
HA?
Why you goin all rumbly bumbloo-
woah. I can't read that! What does that say everybody?
Okay, alright.. kind of slenderman's b-oh
[reading wall] Lulz Fernanda.. Luiz! Sorry! [chuckling] I thought that I said lols..
My bad, I've been on the Internet- woAY
AY
Whoa! what the- AY!
WhAT tHe HElL WaS tHAAT
Hey stop that now.. okay, all right
Bruokay here we go just needed -whoever's blowing into that tuba needed to take a breath
[sound of something breaking]
AHfggst fuck you
[quick, panicked breathing]
Uh.. why? why? why.. why would you do that?
"Nene six lex"  .. alright.. whatever you say Nene..
Why you doing that? This better not just be a jump-scare haunted house walking simulator
[loud bang]
[Panicked breathing returns]
AUGH ITSA JUMPSCARE [Mark noises]
Okay, alright, not that bad. Not that bad. Not that bad. You're  gonna have to do better than that to get me
I've had a lot of experience with jump scares
.. scares that are jumpy..
straaange..
Who's ringing the chimes?
Who's chimen up a storm over there?
wOHO- HEY WHO-oA- WHOOOOA WHAAAT THE HE-AHGH
AAAA
HOo
AaaRu AH
Oooh whyyynyo
That.. was a cool effect. I will admit, but, uh,  why though? is my curious statement
what the h- eheh uh tha-
That hallway's a doozy
That hallway is a ding-dong damn doozy
Maybe there's- maybe there's like, more stuff if I actually go into the, like, corners of these rooms or something
nice bars! no?
nice growth!
No? okay. Lies. All lies.
weird
That was funkalicious. That was something that I've never seen before.. I mean obviously this game on its surface
It's rough around the edges, and, uh, it needs a lot of polish, but
Hey, at least it's got the ambiance down. ooo! alright. Oooh
[reading file] Daniel Soares, ex-military, 32 years old; kidnapping, political crime, smuggling, subversion crime
pronouncement, the prisoner "wa" taken to cell 8 for interrogation
Okay
[Male Screaming]
Boaw
wo-ah
Damn my flashbacks! What the hell? Wait a minute, that wasn't—was that like that before?
And, ah, it's not just you, the frame rates a little low in the game
And I don't know why. It's not even taxing my system very much, but.. there she- wait
Yeah, what the hell? Oh, I get it. That's not supposed to be there [mumbling] broken..
okay, I guess the music done [laughing]
I guess the music is done. The tuba player pa- [music comes back] Oh, no he's back now. He passed out for a little bit, like:
[mocking tuba player] [gasps for air] just need this drink of water.. [glug]
and then [mocks sound of tuba]
Oh. ah.
Here. oh. No? yes? I can't go [male yell]
Or you can let me out. [female voice interrupts from above] wha- what? what came from upstairs?
I just came from upstairs! What are you talking about? I was just there..  ooOO blood.. was that there before?
probably
Okay well.. oh no, it definitely wasn't -
oW wha- hey,  hey! what the.. hey! Luiz? is that you?
All right, okay, see ya soon.. I guess..
[more mumbles] I don't know. I don't know what all this is-
[door creaking]
[high pitch scream]
OOOOou
Very nice. Very nice. Okay. alright. okay. alright. okay. alright. okay.
Alright, oka-wwwhyy?
Where.. why.. oou-kay
All right.. ouoou great great great great
[tuba]
Bah! okay, alrig- this god damn tuba player! He needs to work on his lung capacity! Ah, geez. alright, well, that's
BUwha-wha?
[Cell door creaking]
ugh
kay
Am I free to go?
Am I just.. able to walk on my way?
Ooo! Where'd my flashlight come from?  Have I always had that?
[chuckling] I 've just [clinking sound] Orh
[Voice of female returns]
I don't know if you want to do that..
What wa- WAHAYE
Okay alright okay
Oh.. ooh..
Did I do that? Ohh n.. What the hell? whoa.. waai
[clinking sounds]
How are you doing *that*?
How are you doing that? That's.. really creative.. how- how'dya do that?
I mean, obviously it's a video game, but whatever.. A flashlight with UV light. I don't want to know..
what kind of stains exist in a prison. I just.. don't want to know that.
Ah.. Ooooh.. ah..
Terrible, terrible. "No hope for us" Aha, me neither. Alright.. okay.. alright..
Anyone in there?
A haunted toilet..?
Yeesh, alright. Well.. yeah, you know , you gotta admit this game.. It don't look too great
It-it doesn't have a lot in the way of l— [spooky noise] uoh
It doesn't have a lot in the way of looks
But it does have a lot in the way of like the things that they're trying to do here
It's definitely rough, but as far as like, these indie horror games that are made by either one person or a very small team
This has come a long way, and I played a ton of them in my career on YouTube. I've played..  a TON of them
I've played good, I've played bad, I've played them all, but I got to applaud them for actually trying some new things
[spoopy sounds continue] Aah
Could do-OH
er uh.. ya know.. about that arrow..
I don't know if I trust that
That seems like the NOT thing to do
Er.. I can't get in though..
Alright, okay. alright, okay..
[spooky music has officially replaced tuba boi, we will remember him. Sounds like a spoopy piano]
okay.. Alright..
where you goi- aaAAHAHA
ooh
OA
Where am I?
Where am I..? no- wha.. How did?! How.. wha??
Waaait a minute. Wait a minute wait a minute wait a minute. What the hell?
How did I get back here?
[clicking flashlight on and off]
Oka-  [boards breaking] hEY
Ho.. Alright then, what the hell was that?
Who's busted out of their cell over there?
someone's breaking the rUules
someone's being naughtyyy
wha!
Hello? Hi!
Whoa! I don't know this!
I don't know that code
"Find the three passwords"?  Three passwords? What does that even mean?
Three passwords..?
Where am I gonna find those? Am I gonna loop back around- oou
Okay, stain. Alright.
Alright..
Auuoooh
Oooo! Ah, there I go! Damn it. Alright, so there's gotta be codes on the ground..
[grossed out Mark sounds]
Someone had way too much fun in there!
Aouuagh
All right, so there's got to be three codes somewhere.. Oddly enough the framerate has picked up, and I don't know why..
Ah. OOONE.
Pu.. OOOONNE I found a *ONE*
GUYS
Alright, I found it. Found the ONE
You were looking for the one I found..  whoa
Okay, thought I heard something. Oh, that's—wait
That wasn't like that before—wait that wasn't like that before? Wait a minute.
Oh, do I just got to loop through multiple times and like that's—
They each have different—they- they each have differences? Is that what it is? Okay, that's still one so
There's gotta be other numbers around here somewhere.
OH
Five! I've found a five! ..and a dead body.. I found a five and a dead body!
[low wailing]
Yeah, I'm good, I'm good. I'm good, go back to sleeep. I'm fiiiine
Youu are cool
Very proud of you. Just.. go to hell, and die. -if you're not dead already- just do dat
please
(Mark goes stip-stepping around)
Oh, that's- oh, oh the string section is here.. alright well that's good
One..
Five...
Uh.. [music gets louder]
Oh!
Oooookay?
ahhh OOOo oAHh
Oh, it's the happy chair! Oh look at that smile [nervous laughter]
Look at that award-winning smile on that chair. Alright. Well. That's not good
What's in here I wo— [Sound of someone getting electrocuted]
Sorryy!  ..yeesh
[sound of the electricity goes on]
Sorry... anyway..
kay. Oh no wait; one.. five... someone's not having a good time in there
[sound of man wailing in pain] [door opens]
[man continues to scream in pain]
Uh..
Hello?
[Electricity seems to ramp up again]
Wait, wait, wait! What? He's real??  [stumbling over his words] what??
How the- what? Okay. Find the wire.
Ugh
Follow the wire, follow the wire, okay
Yeah, see like this is what I mean, like this is really creative stuff that is used with like, pretty
Oh. There we go. Yes. Get this. [clunk] There we go. I fixed it! Fixed the problem! Fixed the problem..
Fixed the problem? Yes? No? uh oh
wait.. o-ooh..
Somethin behind me? Somethin behind me?! [Panicked breathing picks up]  aH somethin behind me!
[Scream from Mark's character] OH
[Narration]
I'm trapped on- OOH
ooooOOOOOH
Oh, I thought this game was done. Oh, I thought- I thought this was a whole experience
Ahhh...
That was interesting. That was fascinating. Very interesting.
See like it- it was like I said [Narration interrupts], it looked very basic..
It looked very basic..  Okay..
I already know about this; hang on, hang on. Okay, so not bad.
Not great..
Obviously, it's very very rough.. and anyone would say that, I'll say that, like, it's just true, but
They took what- what could have been a very basic horror game experience
And they transformed it into something
Even better, because they tried new things. And they put just enough polish on it that it worked well
Like the actual experience of the scares worked very well
Despite the way it looked. Still rough around the edges
But I loved that. That was good. It obviously had some heart into it and obviously had a story into it so, very cool
So thank you everybody so much for watching, if you want to play this for yourself
Maybe I missed a few secrets here and there, I'll put a link in the description
And thank you everybody so much for watching. Let me know what you thought down in the comments and as always
I'll see you, in the next video!
Buh-bye!
[Outro Music]